[Музика]
привіт усім, мене звати Анна, і
це урок англійської мови,
тому в 9 класі сьогодні ми продовжуємо роботу
з темою молодіжна культура, ми
збираємося продовжити практикувати герундій та
інфінітив,
а давайте відразу почнемо з вправи
тому наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб прочитати слова
в рамці та вгадати їх значення, тоді ми
повинні використати слова, щоб завершити
запитання, тож давайте подивимося на
слова відповідь назад конфлікти настрої
стрес ризиковані злети та падіння добре, давайте
подивимося на  кожне слово ще раз одне за одним
і з'ясуйте, що вони означають, а
саме прощення прощення не було сумнівом, що
повільніша
дивність Шіри, яку я б не витримав, проблема
була у відпустці, тому, коли я був дитиною, я був
першим і служив назад, тому це
насправді  коли ти відповідаєш комусь
трохи образливо,
наступна конфліктує, тож тоді
люди сперечаються разом і є багато
різних суперечок Муді, тож якщо ти
знаєш слово настрій, ти знаєш, що ти можеш
бути ми  у вас гарний настрій чи поганий
настрій, тож якщо у вас настрій, це означає, що у
вас поганий настрій, тож ви не дуже
добре, вам не подобаються деякі речі, які
відбуваються далі, це стрес
тож напружуватися означає відчувати себе дуже
напруженим,
тому навколо вас виникають стресові ситуації,
і вони змушують вас почувати себе незручно
або
стрес, наступна ризикована, тож
який сенс,
безумовно, щось пов’язане з ризиком,
таким ризикованим означає, що наступна колонія
один і останній підйоми і падіння,
насправді тут ми маємо значення
, яке дуже схоже на переваги, хороші
речі та недоліки, коли ми говоримо
про настрій людини, злети і падіння
можна використовувати, щоб говорити про щось хороше
або щось погане,
тож давайте візьмемо  подивіться на перше
речення і давайте з’ясуємо, яке слово
ми повинні використати, щоб заповнити прогалину тут, то
чи іноді ви відчуваєте, якщо так, чому
ми можемо відчути, де знаходиться слово, яке говорить нам
про почуття, подивіться
один раз на поле  знову так  так, я впевнений, що
ви правильно здогадалися, слово "
примхливе" наступне номер два чи ви
іноді щось робите, якщо так, що це
таке, то яке слово ми можемо використати тут, про
які речі ми говоримо, ймовірно,
ми говоримо  про ризиковані речі, це
правильно,
номер три чи знаєте ви, ваші батьки чи
вчителі, чи знаєте ви, що це ознака поганої
поведінки, то що може бути ознакою поганої
поведінки, коли ви говорите комусь
щось не дуже приємне, коли
хтось говорить вам, як ваші батьки
чи вчителі  а потім ти думаєш: «О, я
не хочу чути, що у мене все гаразд,
тож це означає, що
ви відповісте, і це фраза,
яка нам потрібна тут, ви відповідаєте
своїм батькам чи вчителям на наступне
число  чотири які речі, які ви найбільше
добре,
тут нам знадобиться два слова, щоб
заповнити прогалини, подивіться додайте слова ще
раз, у нас залишилися лише конфлікти, стрес,
підйоми та падіння, так, тут ми
повинні ось слово підкреслити, тож на
що
вас наголошує  виходить го  e більшість номер п’ять, як у
вас було щось у своєму житті,
щоб у нас могли бути різні ситуації, і
ми називали б ці ситуації хорошими
чи поганими, тому це залежить від нашого сприйняття,
тому тут ми будемо використовувати фразу злети та
падіння добре, давайте перейдемо до  наступний
і останній тут номер шість, як
ви щось вирішуєте з іншими людьми, тому,
коли у нас є якісь суперечки,
непорозуміння з іншими людьми,
ми називатимемо їх конфліктами, тому тут ми будемо
використовувати слово конфлікти, звичайно, і
питання звучить так, як ви  вирішуйте
конфлікти з іншими людьми, добре,
тепер, коли ви знаєте слова, тепер,
коли ми виміряли їх з
питаннями до пробілів у питаннях,
ви можете дати йому щось, ви можете зупинитися
тут і подумати, які б були ваші
особисті відповіді на ці запитання  то
чи ти іноді відчуваєш себе Муді, якщо так, чому
те, що тебе найбільше напружує, як
ти справляєшся зі злетами та падіннями і як
ти насправді вирішуєш конфлікти з
іншими людьми зараз, коли у тебе є
давайте перейдемо до невеликого читання,
тому подивіться тут, у нас є вступ
до статті про суперечки і подумайте, якщо
ви згодні чи не згодні з тим, що
говориться у вступі, подивіться тут, у
нас також є три твердження, для яких нам
потрібно знайти  фрази, які підтверджують
цю інформацію як справжнє походження та
наближаються до неї з зупинки дост
аттеа зловмисники уродженець Фразі яки Будай
з горошок дрон вірджинія ти
куніс викликає це не пученко тож давайте
подивимося на заяви перш за
все підлітки номер один використовують неприємні
коментарі, коли вони сперечаються, що підлітки хочуть, щоб
ви відчували себе винними за всі їхні турботи,
підлітки
емоційно сперечаються, тож
це твердження, які нам потрібно знайти
підтверджуючу інформацію в статті,
давайте подивимося на
вступ слово «нерви епідермісу», щоб
уникнути  суперечки з підлітками сперечатися
з підлітком не весело за
роки, вони навчилися способам сперечатися,
які є образливими, повними суворості  asm і
які змушують дорослих відчувати відповідальність за
всі свої проблеми і, що ще гірше,
суперечки з підлітками не корисні,
тому що молоді люди ніколи не замислюються, перш
ніж сказати комусь жахливі речі.
у
будь-якому випадку давайте подивимося на
твердження ще раз і спробуємо
знайти інформацію, яка підтверджує ці
твердження, тож тепер у вас є час
подумати й знайти цю інформацію
самостійно  вісім бітів інформатики
Томас Тіно, а тепер давайте перевіримо
білий вигляд Авіра мо, тож у номері один
ми маємо неприємні коментарі, ця
фраза перефразована у вступі,
щоб вона звучала як способи сперечатися,
які шкодять, наступний – відчувати себе
винним за всі свої  занепокоєння, ця
частина речення перефразована як змушує
дорослих відчувати відповідальність за всі свої
проблеми, тому відчувати себе винними, відчувати відповідальність
бу  Не в гарному сенсі наступне -
емоційно реагувати на суперечки, і ви
можете побачити це тут, в останньому реченні
ніколи не думайте, перш ніж вони скажуть жахливі
речі, тому, коли ви робите щось, не
замислюючись,
ймовірно, ви поводитеся емоційно добре зараз,
коли ми розігрілися  трохи
давайте подивимося на решту
тексту, тепер наше завдання - прочитати
решту статті і сказати, чи є
твердження після нього істинними чи хибними,
ви побачите твердження трохи
пізніше, тепер давайте подивимося на  текст:
підлітки сперечаються, коли відчувають, що
правила занадто обмежені, і коли дорослі
не ставляться до них як до дорослих, вони бунтують,
коли їм говорять, що робити, коли
батьки вибирають одяг, або їхні
друзі, коли дорослі кажуть, коли я був молодим,
усе було інакше, тому  як дорослі можуть
уникнути суперечок з такими молодими
бунтарськими розумами, коли справа доходить до
обговорення проблеми, краще
вислухати підлітків і дозволити їм сказати
те, що вони думають і відчувають, слухати
не означає погоджуватися з  все, що
вони говорять, це просто означає, що до них
ставляться як до партнерів у розмові
. Для підлітків важливо навчитися йти на
компроміс, вони можуть не хотіти йти на
компроміс весь час, але вони повинні
навчитися розуміти, що вони не
завжди можуть робити те, чого хочуть компроміс
вчить підлітків  щоб побачити інші точки
зору, дорослі повинні навчитися давати більше
свободи підліткам, особливо на
вихідних, коли їм пора
розслабитися, хоча просити зателефонувати батькам і
сказати, зачекайте, де вони і що
вони роблять, це компроміс, але це показує,
що  підліткам довіряють, це також
змушує їх відчувати, що дорослі батьки
не повинні жартувати над зовнішністю
своїх дітей-підлітків, що дорослому здається дурним,
для них може бути дуже важливим,
вони повинні знати, що їх
люблять
з хорошими оцінками або без них  школі
також потрібно пам’ятати, що
ніколи не критикувати їх перед іншими,
тому тепер ми прочитали текст і
готові сказати, чи будуть вислови після
чи це правда чи неправда, давайте
подивимося на твердження,
тож перше, що підлітки
сперечаються, коли відчувають, що контролюють свої
рішення, те, що сказано в тексті про
це, є правдою чи неправдою,
це неправда, тому коли
підлітки відчувають, що  вони контролюють свої
рішення, вони, ймовірно, не будуть сперечатися,
чи наступне слухання номер два
допоможе дорослим зрозуміти, що підліткова
точка зору правда чи неправда,
важливо, щоб підліток був почутим
і вислуханий так, звичайно, це
твердження вірне  третій,
підлітки іноді повинні навчитися йти на компроміс,
тож це твердження є правильним
чи неправильним відповідно до того, що ми
прочитали в тексті, добре, це
, звісно, правильно, важливо, щоб пі
літки навчитися йти на компроміс но
ер чотири  потрібна свобода,
щоб почувати себе дорослими, або вони роблять те, що
насправді згадувалося в тексті про це,
звичайно,
це твердження є помилковим підліткам
потрібна свобода, щоб відчувати себе дорослими номер
п'ять, є  деякі речі, які дорослі
не повинні робити, розмовляючи з підлітком, -
це все, що
дорослі можуть робити, коли вони розмовляють з
підлітком, ймовірно, ні, тому це,
звісно, вірне номер шість, текст дає по
ади як дорослим, так і пі
літкам  насправді він дає кілька
порад як для дорослих, так і для підлітків,
так, звичайно,
текст пропонує, що
повинні робити і що не повинні робити обидві вікові групи, тому і
дорослі, і підлітки,
поради цим людям згадуються
в тексті.  молодці, тепер
час перейти до граматики, давайте
подивимося на пари речень тут,
деякі з них утворюють крихітні діалекти, тому наше
завдання полягає в тому, щоб порівняти речення в
парах, тож давайте подивимося на першу
пару речень
, це  крихітний діалект тут о ні, я
зовсім забув подзвонити мамі
, ти забув подзвонити їй годину
тому, то як би ти переклав цей
діалект, як ти розумієш
різницю тут, як ти розумієш тут
ми ха  п’ять різних форм дієслова
після слова забути, отже, спочатку ми говоримо
забув подзвонити, а потім кажемо забув
дзвонити, то яка різниця у
значенні, якщо така різниця у першому реченні
ми говорили про те, що
сталося, що ми повинні були зробити  але
цього не сталося в другому реченні,
ми говоримо про те, що
насправді сталося в минулому, тому, коли ми
їх перекладемо, вони будуть звучати
так, поні, які можна вибирати, Хуаніта, мама,
цей магазин — будка, яка потрібна юкті,
коли новий томо, тож ти можеш
відчуйте різницю тут, це чудово, тепер
давайте перейдемо до другої пари
речень, будь ласка, не забудьте
здати домашнє завдання після уроку. Я взагалі не
пам'ятаю, коли я виконував це завдання, коли
його було призначено, то в чому тут різниця, не
забудьте здати  це ніби
не забудь це зробити Несса Вудс
трохи з моєї будки Немо б Лускін нежа
чоботи дані забруднені Амаш новий робот
Бізлі Якко і є відповідь, яку я
не пам'ятаю зробив  g це завдання взагалі
ми говоримо про минулу дію dr.
Хамза Хелена Паміта Яаков Монро перемісти
куточок Цезаря Даніеля Коленда Мелісса
Дівалі,
тож ось різниця між Х
парами речень, які
я побачив Джейн у неділю, ми зупинилися,
щоб поспілкуватися,
вона все ще така мила Вау,
я насправді думав, що він зупинився
може два роки тому і  ніколи б більше не
розмовляти один з одним,
то яка різниця тут я побачив
Джейн в неділю, ми зупинилися, щоб поспілкуватися,
це означає, що я йшов по
вулиці, а потім я зупинився, щоб
поговорити з Джейн, тому я перестав
ходити, а потім я  розмовляли з Джейн,
а друге речення припускає, що ми
закінчили розмовляти з дорослими, тому ми не
спілкувалися з нею, і це сталося
два роки тому, і відтоді ми взагалі не
спілкувалися, і насправді ми не
збираємося продовжувати це робити, тому якщо ми
перекладіть їх ми скажемо, що мій
супернервовий Джо Берета
ah-ha-ah-ha Lita do macho voice Parris
tollis peccata var okay Tomo то
ось різниця між формою
дієслова, яку ми використовуємо після дієслова stop  так що
припиніть щось робити або перестаньте щось робити,
давайте перейдемо до наступної пари речень,
це також короткий діалог. Я
намагаюся завантажити цей файл протягом години.
Ви намагалися натиснути цю маленьку
кнопку тут, тож у першому реченні ми  ' '
говорю про щось дуже складне
yobsn Омаха каже Іван Таша, що кажуть
файл привів вас додому Гудіні це
дочка загону не сама Ванесса ван
Таша і відповідь є чат,
ймовірно, що не є О все-таки
Мілена Гович іди так в  У першому
реченні ми говоримо про щось
дуже складне, тому ми говоримо спробувати щось зробити,
а в другому реченні ми
говоримо про експерименти, тож ми
говоримо про спроби різних варіантів,
або ямендо Мухаммеда, ймовірно, запекло
в відновленні, чи не ви
Вудро гомо  нудиться, ммм, це все,
окрім Maserati спробуйте плюс спробуйте зробити
щось добре, а остання пара
речень не є діалогом, але
давайте також подивимося на різницю,
про що ми шкодуємо  Повідомляю вас, що
ваша доставка затримується, тому це
звучить занадто офіційно, чи не так,
а про друге я шкодую, що написав своєму
другові вчора ввечері, у мене був поганий настрій,
і я боюся, що мої слова зачепили її, тому
в першому реченні ми повідомляємо
офіційно деяка інформація в
другому реченні, ми просто шкодуємо, ми
шкодуємо про те, що сталося
в минулому, тому в першому реченні це свого
роду офіційний спосіб сказати вибачення,
у другому реченні це коли ви
висловлюєте своє почуття, що ви шкодуєте про
щось, що  ви зробили в минулому добре,
тепер давайте подивимося на вправу,
давайте потренуємося, щоб ці структури
відповідали дієслову плюс герундій або інфінітиву
з правильним значенням, тому тут у нас є
пари слів, пари
структур та їх значення
праворуч, тому  давайте подивимося на перші
пару слів, зупинись і перестань
робити,
ми повинні уявити собі правильні
визначення з правильними варіантами, щоб
ви припинили одну дію, тому що хочете
або потребуєте  o виконайте іншу діяльність або ви
щось робите, а потім зупинилися або
джамаат не був ідеєю найповільніша вершина - це
рух, який спонукає робити лук.
робити так, коли ми зупиняємося, щоб зробити
щось, це означає, що ми призупиняємо певну
діяльність, а потім робимо щось інше,
тоді, можливо, ми повернемося до
попередньої дії, тому тут, звичайно, нам
потрібно зіставити зупинку, щоб зробити, і перше
пояснення, а друге зупинити виконання
Очевидно, це означає, що ви
щось робите, а потім ви припиняєте
наступні пари слів запам'ятати
робити і запам'ятати робити, і ось
значення ви щось робите, а потім ви
згадуєте це пізніше
підхід Джаміра Обами в бізнес-
процесі важко пам'ятати  вам потрібно
щось зробити, і
ви це зробите.
звичайно, це буде другий,
і, як ви можете бачити тут, пам'ятайте, що ви робите
матчі з вами, зробіть щось, а потім
ви згадаєте це пізніше,
добре, давайте перейдемо до наступної пари
слів забути робити і забути робити, тому
ми маємо два значення тут, ви не  t зробити
те, що ви збиралися зробити, і
ви щось зробили, але ні, ви цього не
пам'ятаєте, тож як ви думаєте, яке
слово, структура якого відповідає якому
значенню, насамперед, звичайно, коли
ми забуваємо щось зробити, це означає, що
ми не робимо  зробити щось, що ми хотіли
зробити, вигнання shivoham' ой забудьте виконати
місію Micajah з кульовими шоу
через британський готель Jammu ropa de OCHA
так, будка каже, що Роберто має випивку,
але каже про обід, а наступна
забуде щось зробити  ти щось зробив,
але ти не пам'ятаєш, як робив
це
muy mas lavash Арабелла інші рухи
часто час прем'єри о так, Девід
Моралес, так і остання пара слів,
як робити і любити робити так, ви,
мабуть, пам'ятаєте, що в th  На
початку теми ми сказали, що з
дієсловами любити і не любити, наприклад,
любити, не любити і ненавидіти, ми зазвичай використовуємо ing,
але, як ви бачите, також
можна використовувати інфінітив, є різниця у
значенні, звичайно, давайте з’ясуємо,
тому  ми або робимо щось, тому що нам
подобається це робити. О, Джиммі показує Робіну
диктору зробити фото самостійно, або ви
робите щось, тому що думаєте, що це
хороша ідея, коли Обама показує, що це трішки, він
каже, що це звичайний день, тож
яка б різниця  яку
форму дієслова ми будемо використовувати після like для
вираження значень, зазначених
тут, тож давайте перевіримо, коли нам подобається щось робити,
це означає, що нам це подобається, а
коли нам подобається щось робити, це означає,
що насправді ми вважаємо, що це гарна ідея,
це  добре зробити щось так
чи інакше добре тепер, коли ми
переглянули відмінності між
значеннями тут, давайте перейдемо до практики, наше
завдання полягає в тому, щоб вибрати правильну
альтернативу, тому номер один я пам’ятаю
грати pl  ане з планшетом, коли я був
молодим, так що пам'ятайте, що робив щось у
минулому або не забудьте зробити щось у
майбутньому, тому, коли я був молодим,
безперечно, я пам'ятаю, як грав
із планшетом, коли був молодим,
ми говоримо про наші  минулі
спогади
тут друге, вчителі сердиться,
тому що я забув зробити або зробити
домашнє завдання
О, Джая Забу, Роберта дамаш, потребує
дев'яти, але вона епімер теріякі аеробна
дамаш новина про Дані, ймовірно,
вчитель розчарований і злий,
тому що учень не приніс
домашнє завдання до школи, тому людина, яку
учень не закінчив або взагалі не зробив
домашнє завдання, тут ми будемо використовувати
інфінітив я забув зробити домашнє
завдання наступне число три я люблю ходити
або ходити до стоматолога двічі на рік
мені подобається  ходити до стоматолога двічі на рік,
я не думаю, що, ймовірно, у світі не так багато
людей, які дійсно люблять
ходити до стоматолога, тому ми, ймовірно,
вважаємо, що це гарна ідея проходити огляди
у стоматолога  двічі на рік О Джейд моя
піхва розбивати її OSHA в день при
дозуванні ядро не закривається або ніж це, що
Chenery Oh mija Waterman a pro enjoy
Omaha завтра хороша ідея, тому тут ми
удемо використовувати інфінітив I lik
to go to dentist two
наступного року номер чотири ми перестали
їсти або їсти, тому що були голодні або
Джен ми віримо в тебе, коли
Супанова каже, що Чопра Пасхальний Джиммі Паріс підраховує
Х'юстон, тому ми перестали їсти або ми
перестали їсти, коли ми говоримо, що перестали
їсти, що це означає  що ми взагалі не
їли, тому ми закінчили їсти тут,
нам потрібно використати інфінітив, звичайно,
тому ми перестали їсти з аналізом супу
робота бариста наступний номер п'ять
ти забув принести чи принести каструлю
не хвилюйся я  У мене є запасний,
який показує, що обидва вимовляють rich
con neck Volusia через багато років, тому
тут ми будемо використовувати інфінітив,
звичайно, чи ви забули взяти з собою ручку,
ми не говоримо про минулі спогади, тому
нам не потрібно  ing наступний
nu  Шість, чи можете ви не пам'ятати, щоб дати або
віддати це Дену, коли побачите його
завтра, чи
можете ви згадати, чи ми говоримо про
минулі спогади чи ми говоримо про
щось, що людині потрібно зробити
в майбутньому,
так, що буде другим засобом чи
Джаміла нижня частина захисту тепер дитина
знає родича моя попочка Немо їжа özkan
там вибір буча скинути з тут ми
будемо використовувати інфінітив
чи не забудь, щоб дати його Дену, коли
побачиш його завтра
номер сьом, ти живеш по-справжньому здоровим тепер
, коли зупинився  їсти або їсти
нездорову їжу тут ми, мабуть, поговоримо про
щось, що закінчилося, так що це
закінчена дія людина більше не їсть
нездорову їжу
ви не заперечували Paris Tala це так,
нестерова звичайна, тому тут ми будемо використовувати
ing of  Звичайно, щоб виразити саме це
значення або зробити Tocco shop, тому що
на саміті каже, що тепер вона згадала емодзі,
що таке король-молодший.  Я NGVs Lobby добре харчуюся,
а останній номер
восьмий мій тато любить вставати або вставати,
тому що це означає, що він також може закінчити роботу
раніше,
тож він любить отримувати або насититися, тому
тут ми будемо використовувати ing, щоб він любив
прокидатися  вранці дуже рано,
тому що це допомагає йому робити багато
речей добре, а ще одна
вправа, наше завдання - вирішити,
правильні речення чи неправильні,
і ми перепишемо неправильні
речення номер один. Я маю повернутися
додому, тому що я забув  вимикач у духовці
вимкнено, тому я забув перемикання, це
правильно, ми говоримо про наші
спогади, наче я не пам’ятаю перемикач
у духовці ні, ми насправді говоримо
про те, що ми забули це зробити
так, над новим шаблоном о, я забув
вимкніть духовку номер два чи можете ви
пам’ятати, що ви принесли мені мою книгу завтра,
тому що вона мені потрібна,
щоб ви пам’ятали, що
принесіть це правильно чи правильно говорити про
майбутні дії, які ми повинні робити.
lk про
спогади, тож тут нам потрібен інфінітив,
звичайно, чи можете ви запам’ятати, щоб мозку Naza
bootprint, як більше ви підключаєтесь О
номер три, я думаю, що настав час
почати переглядати для іспиту, тож ми можемо
почати переглядати так, звичайно, це речення
правильне  номер чотири зупинись, щоб грати цю
пісню, тому що це жахливо, тому зупинись, щоб грати
так, тут у нас є інфінітив до плюс
інфінітив чи правильно використовувати його так,
безумовно, не ми говоримо про
завершення дії, тому нам потрібно використовувати
площину ing stop  Палестина, ти пішов,
це миролюбивий наступний номер п'ять.
Я люблю вставати рано, коли в мене
іспит, тому я люблю вставати рано, коли у
мене іспит, мені це подобається чи я думаю, що
це просто гарна ідея прокидатися  рано
і не бути в черзі
і готуватися до іспиту так,
друге значення тут буде правильним,
тому нам потрібно змінити інфінітив на
інфінітив я люблю вставати, тому що я
вважаю, що це гарна ідея наступного
не робити  хвилюйся, я не забуду надіслати тобі
emai  Коли тебе немає, чи це правильно, чи
можна сказати, що я не забуду надіслати тобі
електронні листи, коли тебе не
буде.
здобич Немо, тож ми
говоримо про щось, що станеться
в майбутньому, тут ми використовуємо
інфінітив 7, тепер я завжди буду пам'ятати, що
зустрівся з тобою
вперше минулого літа, чи це не
звучить для тебе незграбним, так,
безперечно, є помилка  у цьому реченні, тому
нам потрібно змінити інфінітив на ing
I'll always Remember meet you dr.
dibadeaux Pamir навчив тріо яка Му
м’яку хурму Aloha Lita і останнє
речення тут я так люблю відеоігри,
що я не думаю, що коли-небудь перестану
в них грати, це речення правильне чи
неправильне, чи потрібно нам
змінити  щось тут
насправді ні, ми просто зберігаємо це, оскільки я
ніколи не перестану грати я ніколи не закінчу
грати у відеоігри, добре зроблено,
тепер давайте перейдемо до домашнього завдання,
тому наступний урок буде
останнім з цієї теми, ваше завдання
переглянути свої правила використання герундію
та інфінітиву і, звичайно, не
забувайте про лексику, яку ми
вивчали через цю тему, добре,
велике дякую і до зустрічі наступного
разу
[Музика]